[Music]
this is pretty close to a perfect
morning
we got a beautiful sunrise coming up
here
that's beautiful
heavenly
and the cows think so as
[Music]
they're well that grass
[Music]
it's cold today and windy
and so i wanted to get this baby calf
picked up and brought him in here would
be nice and warm and dry there you go
little feller
as you can see these cows mean a lot to
me
when i was growing up as a kid i was
assigned to take care of the baby calves
and
i've learned how to love them and how to
care for them
i think they feel loved just as much as
any one of us do
the cow is what she eats in order to
have high quality great tasting milk
we've got to have her eating high
quality great tasting food as well
cows are kind of like any one of us
they've got likes and dislikes and
they're not afraid to voice their
opinion by moving at you
[Applause]
cows naturally love to eat grass that'd
be their number one choice
when our soil is healthy that's what
creates the right quality of crop for
the cows
we strive to plant the pasture with a
variety of different species in our
grass to create biodiversity
these legumes
or clovers they offer different types of
nutrients for the cows
each one of these plants holds carbon
dioxide out of the atmosphere and places
it into the soil is carbon
you'll notice as these cows are walking
around they're releasing the manure
across the grass and the cows will stomp
this down into the soil and this will
become a nutrient source
within the soil is a little ecosystem
all of its own there's all sorts of
little organisms that live in there and
if i mistreat my ground then the soil
will be depleted
horizon organic supports family farms by
helping us have the know-how that we
need to ensure that our soil is being
protected and to be able to market our
milk throughout the country we all have
the the same goal to produce the very
best milk possible
i take great pride in my family farm
millions of people expect me to take
good care of my animals and my crops so
that they have clean healthy food to eat
every day
you want to be a farmer haas
what about you stagger you want to drive
big tractors
[Music]
one thing that is everlasting is the
soil
i'm farming the soil that my grandpa and
my great grandpa my dad farmed and it
brings me
a huge amount of joy to not only myself
but my family
[Music]
you